jefff let's have a look at the replay
here to see if indeed he did do the
three pumps all right no question there
is the first one right agreed right and
then coming
up is the second one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
up right here oh yeah you're right
there's absolutely three pumps
there hi everybody I'm Dave stasson
alongside Jeff worthy and welcome to the
annual East West pole as we get ready to
watch some of the best college players
of the nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads aren't there Jeff
that's right Dave it does seem like the
most flamboyant personalities came to
the Forefront and they are here let's
meet the players from the
[Music]
East Demarcus Williams University of
Georgia TJ Json Wayne State Unity
tar n King Mar m College to Royal
smoochi Wallace University of Miami
dequarius green Jr University of Notre
Dame ibraim muus University of Tennessee
at Chattanooga Jack Marius T theat
tricks Michigan State University the
Isaiah T Billings CL K Carolina
University The Jasper proen krux I third
South Carolina State University Lear
Maxwell jillions East Carolina
University jabarus Jamar jabarus and
Lamar University of midle Tennessee Theo
shower
handle University of Southern
Mississippi Hingle mccringleberry Penn
State University lar Petron Duke
Marriot Florida Atlantic University the
Dinklage University of South
Florida X Miss Jackson flax and waxing
California University of
Pennsylvania we're going to be looking
for big plays all game long from Tyro
smoochi Wallace and let's not forget the
tight ends Ibraham muus and hangle
mccringleberry they've both had amazing
season that's right Jeff now let's meet
the players from the
West vagitarian Jeffers spin Texas A&M
the gler dunk University of Wisconsin
Swan El Gooding Splat sukwan University
quo quo San Jose State University osz
buckshank Stanford University these are
12 washing beard Jones college Shakira
Quan TGF Carter University of Northern
Arizona X Wayne at alicious Missouri
Western State University sequester rli
MD Adam State sco phos Raptor malloys
South Dakota State University TJ AJ RJ
back slashing forth the 5ifth albian
College San Diego State University
donkey teeth Boise State University
torque lewith Nevada state Penitentiary
the player formerly known as Mouse
cop University of Missouri Columbia Dan
Smith
BYU and we're coming to the end of the
first quarter with the Rhinos in the red
zone for the first time got to say Bill
I like watching these rhinos Ransom
takes the snap drops back with good
protection and that's a completed pass
to a very wide open Hingle
mccringleberry the rookie out of Penn
State nice grab by mccringleberry you
think he's happy oh boy he's is loving
it down there oh we got something of a
shooting gallery going on oh yeah look
at that boy that is something and oh oh
wait we got a flag there got that for
excessive celebration well see I'm not
sure about that call I don't know Bill
that was three pumps and the rule book
says you cannot have more than two oh my
gosh but look at the kid he's pleading
his case with the ref pleading his case
yeah clearly three PPS Coast Johnson
definitely not happy about this call 5
minutes into the fourth quarter third
and 10 the Rhinos again threatening to
score can the Cougars hold them big play
coming here Bill Ransom takes the snap
drops back he floats one into the end
zone and mccringleberry pulls it down oh
he's got it oh my gosh for his second
touchdown of the day for this rookie he
has got to be feeling great about
himself of conf I'll tell you man he's
Oh see now there's two pumps yeah he's
really testing the boundaries and he's
clearly gotten the ref's attention here
a third pump will draw a flag no matter
what see oh he just did it again what
now what is that the second time now you
have to flag him on that yeah he had to
you know bill it's just frustrating
seeing young players without the ability
to restrain themselves oh it really is
it it's hard I mean the ref's going to
get you every time yeah yeah absolutely
uh see now the ref agrees that's three
pumps right
there and the quarterback Ransom under
Center last five minutes of the game
rhinos are Marching here again hard to
stop this team from scoring build they
have so many weapons Ransom takes the
snap and it's a shovel pass the
mccringleberry oh he's at the 10 he's at
the five and touchdown oh my great block
by hard dunach chut and that's going to
be tough for the Cougars to come back
from boy what a career day from Hingle
MC crinkle Berry the rookie out of Penn
State oh he is just amazingly fired up
here today Jeff you got to love the way
this guy plays and he oh oh see now
there's one pump well I cannot believe
this kid you got to put your team first
in situations like this and
mccringleberry's just not doing that now
there's two Jeff now if he pumps a third
time he will draw his third penalty for
today everybody here waiting with bed
breath he did it oh did he yes he did it
oh that's he couldn't help himself
amazing I mean come on in professional
football it's really it's a shame that's
what it is you can argue all you want
but the flag well it's been thrown
that's right if it's three pumps the
ref's not going to take it away now no
he's not duration and intensity doesn't
make any difference Jeff let's have a
look at the replay here to see if indeed
he did do the three pumps all right no
question there is the first one right
agreed and then coming up
is the second one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
up right here oh yeah you're right
there's absolutely three pumps there oh
uh apologies to all those watching with
young children uh clearly
unintentional but
I